one two met Pat's coming for you three
four with a feeling about Google five
six
throw some science in the mix seven
eight gonna settle the debate nine ten
ready won't kill again hello Internet
welcome to film theory admittedly it's
scary these days there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world and things feel
really out of control so today we're
taking control back into our own hands
weren't taken one of the scariest most
powerful monsters in all of horror
cinema one who attacks when we're most
helpless when we're asleep and were
beating him at his own game we're
learning how to defeat the dream killer
Freddy Krueger's loyal theorists
grandpappy Matt Pat wants to take you on
a stroll down memory lane to the time
when he was a wee little child and still
went to Blockbuster Bree see kids in
those days Blockbuster still existed now
I loved the video store partially for
the video game rentals harshly for the
sour patch kids and partially for the
mystery of whatever was in that back
room with the red light that my dad
liked so much was it World War 2
documentaries knowing my dad was
probably World War 2 documentaries yes
I'll never know anyway my other memories
of going to blockbuster include timidly
walking down the horror movie aisle a
young mind curious about all those scary
r-rated movies that I was too young and
too much of a chicken to watch I was
always careful not to stop and look too
long at any of the boxes because even
those were enough to give me nightmares
a giant shark looming under an
unsuspecting swimmer still the reason I
don't swim death spa you'll sweat blood
it's still the reason I don't exercise a
green goo Li popping out of the toilet
still the reason I don't you get the
idea
prep an extra set of bed sheets MA cuz
baby pad is waking up damned but for the
best 80s horror classics that dominated
those VHS displays a Nightmare on Elm
Street is probably the most memorable
for one just because there are so many
of them after the original came out in
1984 The Nightmare on Elm Street
franchise created four sequels in less
than five years it's a release calendar
that would make the likes of Scott
Cawthon jealous but as a kid with just a
passing knowledge of the horror movie
universe Freddy is probably the monster
who scared me the most sure Jason
Voorhees is more imposing and
bloodthirsty but I didn't go to camp or
space for that matter which seemed like
the main prerequisite for getting killed
by him pinhead yeah can't solve a
Rubik's Cube to save my life but Freddy
Krueger a monster who attacks in your
dreams seems like cheating to make
matters even creepier Wes Craven was
inspired by the real story of several
refugees who died suddenly and
inexplicably in their sleep something we
just talked about recently over on game
theory in fact link is in the corner but
yeah Freddy is not only inescapable he's
actually based on something real what
defense do we have against all of that
none or Floyd thought for the last 25
years but friends today it's time to put
Freddy to sleep for good that's right
theorists you can all sleep a little
tighter tonight after watching this
episode because we're gonna show you how
to survive Freddy Krueger and keep him
confined to Dreamland once and for all
turn out the lights and tuck yourself in
it's time to put Freddy to Betty and
yeah and well that line was cheesy but
it's on brand for these movies I mean
have you heard the lines this guy uses
his puns are worse than mine I rest my
case the first step in learning how to
defeat Freddy Krueger is to study all
the times that he's been defeated in the
past to see if we can get any pointers
from there and so I called in the expert
the master of all things horror and gore
here on YouTube it's none other than
James a Jenice from the YouTube channel
dead meet the man who is most known for
counting all the dead bodies in every
single horror movie out there a concept
that I may or may not have ripped off
for my Disney death series I just loved
his work but figured he wouldn't do it
to Mulan any time soon so I took it upon
myself James what do you got to say
about Freddy hey buddy thanks for
including me in this video in the
original and Nightmare on Elm Street
Freddy is pulled out of the dream world
and is burned by a Molotov cocktail
except that doesn't quite finish the job
our final girl Nancy realizes that
without fear Freddy has no power so she
just turns her back on in many vaporizes
apparently Freddy's life force is
roughly the same as Tinker Bell's
because
if you ignore them they die only in
Freddie's case he comes back and in a
Nightmare on Elm Street two Freddy's
revenge he possesses a teenage boy to
kill for him until his girlfriend sees
the only way to defeat Freddy is by
kissing him and freeing her boyfriend's
soul that's trapped inside of him in a
Nightmare on Elm Street three dream
warriors Freddy is a terrorizing a
pediatric psych ward and we get the back
story that he's a real son of a nun
whose bones need to be laid to rest this
time he's killed when his bones are
doused in holy water and topped with a
cross because of the power of Jesus I
guess a nightmare down street for the
dream master gives Freddy the Medusa
treatment when our new final girl Alice
recites a nursery rhyme and makes Freddy
look at his own reflection that causes
the souls inside of him to rip him to
shreds one of his Souls is played by
Linnea Quigley fun fact the fifth
installation the dream child has Freddy
lose to his demon apprentice who turns
Freddy into a baby it's just as stupid
as it sounds other installments go
Freddy via bomb decapitation throat
attack so basically we've got two
takeaway lessons here one there is no
reliable or consistent way to kill
Freddy and prevent him from ever coming
back and to not even dream demons are
immune to dope rhymes nursery rhymes
that is so if there's no offensive
strategy to kill Freddy then what are
our defensive options for keeping him
from killing us the first is the most
obvious one don't sleep I know just what
you're saying and it's dumb
unfortunately this isn't the best
solution not because we're bad at not
sleeping quite the contrary in fact
according to the CDC one in three
Americans isn't getting enough sleep and
that's without us even trying no the
problem is that we will always always
end up falling asleep at the end of long
periods of staying awake in the 1960s a
high school student named Randy Gardner
broke the record for the longest stretch
of being awake at 11 days 25 minutes
which he did for a school project well
you know what he did when it was all
over fall asleep for a total of 25 hours
spread across two days and Freddy is a
patient man he waited several years
between being burned by the parents of
Springwood Ohio and eventually taking
his revenge on their kids so even if you
stay up for a solid week playing
Minecraft he'll catch you right when
you're about to start dreaming of
diamond
I mean you could try to push Randi
Gardner's record but that's also gonna
run you into a lot of problems there are
no known cases of a human death caused
by a simple lack of sleep but tests have
been done to monitor the effects of
extreme sleep deprivation on lab rats
because apparently scientists are in a
constant competition to see who can kill
rats in the most creatively cruel way
possible after about a month all the
rats were dead due to mysterious reasons
but suspected all the reasons were tied
back to their lack of sleep again I go
into way more detail about all of these
things over on that game theory episode
it's almost as if these two episodes
were meant to be watched together and
somehow the programming schedule got
shifted in some way go figure
anyway suffice it to say that the length
of time which humans could stay awake
without dying is probably not identical
to that of rats but there's no reason to
believe that it'd be significantly
longer so basically we find ourselves in
a catch-22 here if you asleep
Freddie is gonna kill you if you don't
sleep your body is gonna kill you so
what is the answer then well remember
that Freddie isn't just a killer who
attacks in our sleep he's a killer who
attacks in our dreams no dreams no
Freddie we're not always dreaming when
we sleep realistically the vast majority
of our dreams and pretty much any dream
you to actually remember takes place
during rapid eye movement or REM cycles
of sleep I would insert another 90s
music joke here but you know copyright
issues so just know that the thought was
there and it's just a missed opportunity
for everyone
REM sleep usually occurs in about ten
minutes at the end of the sleep cycle
which lasts roughly nine minutes the
longer you sleep the longer those REM
cycles will become so one possibility is
sleeping for shorter periods that
prevent us from going into REM and that
brings us to our next candidate to
defeating Freddie polyphasic sleep most
people engage in what's known as mono
phasic sleep you're awake all day to go
to bed for one long stretch at night you
wake up you rinse you repeat polyphasic
sleep on the other hand seeks to boost
productivity by giving people shorter
separated periods of sleep throughout
the day it was allegedly used by
Leonardo da Vinci who I think I can
safely say was a reasonably productive
dude the most popular versions of
polyphasic sleep tend to still have a
longer stretch of sleep at night with
some naps sprinkled throughout the day
but both the uberman and Dymaxion models
call for no more than 30 minutes of
sleep at a time foolproof plan writes
not so fast
for one medical professionals are very
is about the benefits of polyphasic
sleep a doctor from the UCLA sleep
disorder center was quoted in Time
magazine as saying quote there is very
little data
none whatsoever in the medical
literature of carefully designed
clinical studies demonstrating that
polyphasic sleep has any advantage in
human sleep medicine end quote
well thanks a lot dr. killjoy but even
if polyphasic sleep isn't exactly good
for you it's still a cheat code to
getting around REM sleep right no once
you start depriving your body of sleep
it actually starts to enter REM sleep
faster than it otherwise would a big
selling point for people who advocate
polyphasic sleep is that it should in
fact increase the amount of time that
you're spending in REM sleep so
paradoxically enough less sleep actually
means more REM and more RAM means more
dreams and more dreams means more Freddy
so the real question is how do we sleep
while avoiding REM altogether and that
requires a little more understanding of
how REM works in the brain
most of the neural activity that takes
place during REM sleep comes from the
brainstem in particular the pontine
tegmentum and locus karolius but if
you're thinking we can just deactivate
those parts of the brain or any other
parts that contribute to remand dreaming
that's sort of like dealing with a
clogged toilet by burning down your
house take away much function from the
brainstem and all of a sudden you're
gonna have a lot of problems with muscle
control including the ones that you need
to pump your heart and help you breathe
so if the goal is still not to die well
that's a no-go solution there are some
very early indications that REM can be
turned on and off by the activation of
certain neurons this has only occurred
in mice that were genetically engineered
to have certain receptors to allow
scientists to control their brains that
way because again the scientists are
just bored little kids who make rats
stay awake until they die and like to
control mouse brains with lights soap
from the brains electrical perspective
you're probably stuck with REM sleep but
there are also chemical reactions in
your brain that are required for REM to
take place and that my friends is where
we finally find our answer for the
chemical reaction to trigger REM sleep
our brain needs to produce a lot of the
neurotransmitter acetylcholine and they
need to eliminate mono amine
neurotransmitters like norepinephrine
and serotonin you don't really want to
get rid of your brain's ability to
produce acetylcholine as that's gonna
lead to issues like weakness fatigue
cognitive impairment constipation
chronic inflammation however if you can
keep your brain from removing
those other neurotransmitters the motto
amine neurotransmitters you can nip REM
sleep right in the bud and lucky enough
for us there's a whole class of drugs
that'll do exactly that monoamine
oxidase inhibitors also known as Mao is
are a class of antidepressants that were
developed in the 1950s and are still
being used today though less often than
the selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors or SSRIs that many are
familiar with to treat things like panic
disorders atypical depression PTSD and
other conditions the whole job of Mao is
is to promote the brain's production of
the exact neurotransmitters that the
brain needs to sweep away in order to
produce REM sleep people who take Mao is
have been observed to have their REM
sleep effectively eradicated from their
nights now I know what you're gonna say
okay matpat but there's always a catch
now you're gonna tell me that not having
REM sleep is gonna make your eyes bleed
or turn your toes into cocktail sausages
or something weird and I understand why
you'd think that
I do like throwing in that there's a
catch but in this case the twist is that
there is no twist multiple scientists
have described people without REM sleep
is experiencing no real defects and
being at no particular health risk so
interestingly enough if you've got panic
attacks or PTSD as a result of Freddy
Krueger the same drugs that you would
have taken to address the effects are
actually the same drugs that you're
gonna need to get rid of the cause in
the first place those are the things
that are gonna keep you safe more
monoamine neurotransmitters equals less
REM sleep equals zero
Freddy wait a second if Freddy Krueger
is defeated by antidepressants does that
mean that the whole nightmare and Elm
Street franchise is about mental illness
this idea of a silent killer one only
you can see that operates in your brain
and can be deadly if it's not dealt with
makes a lot of sense maybe a Nightmare
on Elm Street was actually more
sensitive more culturally aware more
subtle than we could have ever thought
or you know maybe not that all series
can be winners but hey do me a favor and
go check out James's channel dead meat
like I said his channel is great if you
are a fan of horror movies then well
chances are you've probably seen his
channel here on YouTube because he is
the man when it comes to counting all
the deaths in your favorite and also
least favorite never-before-heard from
horror movies out there anyway his
channel is great his podcast is great
and he is just a fantastic really nice
guy so please show him some love click
the link that you see on screen and
leave in the comments below that you
came from the film theorist Channel and
I don't know if you can do me a favor
and work into your comment the word
dongle you can say the word dongle
somewhere in your comment that would be
awesome you can say like hey man Pat
sent me stop stealing his dongle so
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching thank you for showing James
from dead meat some love and remember
that's just a theory a film theory and
sweet dreams